[Music]
wow
that's a whole goddamn title sequence hi
welcome to the baby in yellow the baby
in yellow is a game that i played i
believe in a three scary games way that
one and now it has been promoted out of
the three scary games beginner leagues
into its own standalone video it's an
honor i think anyway but apparently
there's been a lot of updates to this
game and
there's a plushie i don't know what any
of this means big head mode
hats
doctor's gift i don't know what that
means
anyway let's check this out let's see if
anything's different
i don't know if anything is
but to be perfectly honest it was kind
of fun before so if i to play it again
hi
well this is familiar
hello
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
i didn't mean that
well i know what kind of demon you are
so i know that's actually not hurting
you so
i'm not the biggest deal in the world
baby baby ball turtle
there you go
baby's dirty
oh what happened to your knee
what happened to your knee
all right good new nappy god noon oh no
not this again hey cat
run
a soul trapped by the baby in yellow has
been set free um
hmm
oh
good
the souls of the damned are currently
trapped well baby um before any of that
happens
doctor's gift
i don't know what the doctor's gift is
the doctor's gift sounds ominous and
terrifying
and i don't want any part of it
ah
what
did you say i don't know why i'm
carrying this nappy with me
okay baby i'll be right back excuse me
oh
hello oh
requires matching key what
what
what in the
that game that i could granny
am i looking at
snow
a curiosity in july
following such a sweet spring
it started when i took this job
but i was not the first
they are with me
[Applause]
they they are with you they
they night fell the first day
and the hours dragged on
still we cared for the child
[Applause]
[Music]
we spoke of hasta and casilda in their
absence
while outside the fog rolled in as the
cloud waves roll and break on the walls
okay you could you could make this all
one recording to be perfectly honest
with such innocent eyes
clear as crystal
understood by the ignorance and wise
alike
more precious than jewels
more soothing than music
more awful than death
well i mean there are things worse than
death i guess then
as i fell
i knew that the baby in yellow had
opened their tattered mantle
and there was only gods to cry to now
okay well this all seems very bombastic
and profound i don't know why can i put
the baby in the washing machine
it's okay the baby's a demon it's not
really a baby the baby in yellow i
should specify specifically the baby in
yellow
[Music]
no why would you want that in your house
huh
hello
[Music]
hide away
come on
come on
oh you
hey
is there something i get for doing
more of these
i think i did that before
block
kingpiece
this seems important
this seems oddly important hi baby i'll
get you in a second don't worry about a
thing
everything's just fine i think i can
open to the toy box now
one more soul
fine you know
wow okay baby
why don't you just get on the table and
why don't you stay there huh
why don't you stay there huh are you
still there yeah there you are okay uh
good baby
awesome good baby i'm just looking for
cats baby
let me know if you see anything on this
low low ground okay baby you want to go
to bed you know go betty bye you go baby
bye boink
all right good job cat story book oh
let me tell you a story
let me tell you a story
across the shore in distant lands
with dark stars overhead yeah it's a
good job the prince was fast asleep
until a cat jumped on his bed
i found a secret garden
said the cat with much delight
excitedly they ran outside explorers in
the night
that's pretty good honestly
they walked through the golden garden
gate
look at the pretty trees
they walked along the pretty pebble path
look at the colorful flowers
they walked past the fabulous flowing
fountain
look at the dancing water
look
look
look
okay
but the prince didn't like the garden
and started kicking down the trees
he dug up flowers grabbed the hedges and
pulled off all the leaves
he ruined everything for fun the cat
watched on in fear
what a mistake i made the cat cried out
i should never have bought him here
yeah you right and lesson learned
oh
out cold are you
out cold okay time for a nap
so far this is the same as the first
game with this with a few minor
additions like the require
baby
oh no
[Applause]
baby
but
the key to secrets oh
ah whoa
hey
oh my god what is it whoa
oh
okay well this is a whoa
my god
oh my god
oh my
oh my
oh my
okay
ah look closer oh but what if there's
something standing right behind me
what if the thing behind me has changed
okay
no
i that was much closer than i was hoping
[Music]
uh
i seem to have gone far beyond my
babysitting duties
hello kitty
how are you kitty
oh my god
black cat arrives in 2022
soon
what does that even mean
hat hat the cat was fat and shot on a
hat
the cat said the fat hat in the cat
cat had sad fat in the hat cat all right
fine all right the baby's crying i guess
i guess i gotta
talk to the baby or something
i don't think that crack was there
either
[Music]
okay baby okay it's gonna be all right
it's gonna be okay
oh
baby
oh baby
you wanna go to bed wonk wonk you won't
go bad you won't go bad all wonk wonk
blank oh don't worry little boy boy
there you go
put the correct plushie in the
correct bless you what about the
goat
oh okay what about the bonnie
okay what about the cat
okay
good
are you go to bed now i'm not gonna read
you another story because i only have a
standard quota it's a personal policy of
only one book a day no more no less okay
goodbye
i'm chilling out
i'm chilling out
but there was also that chess piece i
know that's probably important somehow i
don't know how but i know it's important
so i'm going to keep that in mind as i
blaze forward without ever thinking
about what i'm doing
look look isn't it funny i told you not
to do that
i've told you not to do that big head
mode hell yeah ultra low definition hell
yeah
wow this is ultra low definition
[Music]
wow you know they weren't kidding
okay i gotta feed the big come here baby
jaw don't look at me like that i'm gonna
turn off ultraload
leave big head mode on though
baby would you like a bottle
stay there baby
wow there was no
what
what
what
ah well let me just make sure there's no
other cats here
well i found the bottle and you're gone
okay
bye baby
okay let's take you to the table let's
take you to the table now i'm gonna keep
my eye on you
i'm watching you
i'm watching you
oh okay that's weird
that's a little weird
okay
this is um
oh
hi
um
okay that's bizarre
i feel like i should be
i feel like i should be a bit more
concerned about this this is a bit
magical and weird hello
i don't think we're supposed to be in
here
i don't think
well
i think you missed
uh what's with that why is that strange
oh toy boxes
good um
ah
interesting or not an emergency are you
sure about that what does this say
ah fun
june 3rd 24th not the 26th
robert cat crown crown i 4 000
okay
fascinating okay uh baby uh
sorry that took a while um i'll look at
that in a moment hey baby
ah baby
i'll be right back i gotta look at the
toys
okay
i was gonna
i i was gonna okay basketball nice train
block doctor
balloon
random random ladle
ah that kind of doctor
i see
i see where'd it go i kicked it would
you like a doctor
would you like a doctor
wow
maybe i'll try to give that to him in
bed
let me just
okay what am i why whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
holy cow
we're just gonna leave that there and
i'm gonna put this baby to bed
come on baby
with your big head in your stupid eyes
oh
boink all right let's read the book
all right how would you like a story of
the prince and the rabbit sure this
one's good
when the rabbit came to visit
the prince said time to play
but his big red eyes they scared her and
she didn't want to stay
quickly towards the exit the tiny rabbit
hopped
the prince ran right behind her and
screamed she must be stopped
oh dear
hey whoa it's the eyeball
and the doctors
why are the eyeballs in the doctors here
[Music]
what put the correct plushie in the spot
there you go okay that's a little rude
um what happened to the glowing eyeball
oh hayes would you like this
okay
oh don't give the baby the thing
don't give the baby the thing
the answer was not to give the baby the
thing
okay
i'm dead now
let's try that again maybe with less uh
goofing around okay baby
there you go good baby
okay i'm gonna ignore that again just
like i ignored it before
and i'm gonna put you right to bed
and then i'm gonna read you a story
okay here we go
oh
okay that's a little rude
i know what you want you want the bunny
i know
okay all right
through dark corridors he chased her hop
hop hop
a relentless futile flight hop hop hop
round and round inside the palace in and
out of space and sight
hop
hop hop
the princey couldn't catch her his heart
was filled with wrath
the rabbit slipped right out the door
and vanished down the path
the prince cried out i need new friends
more now another
i'll bring you some don't worry now
replied his loving
caring
mother
and baby's asleep wow
that must hurt but oh well a good night
baby i don't know where more
cats would be hello
[Music]
hello
hello ah oh
hello
i did not realize that there would be
more
outside
hello
hello
hello
here
okay
well nothing to do here for now but now
i can make toasties
okay put the box on the lounge table
yeah i guess that makes sense
lounge table what's the lounge table
what is the lounge table what do you
mean by lounge table lounge table
lounge table lounge i don't see a lounge
in here and i don't know what a lounge
table means what do you mean by lounge
table
lounge
lounge table
oh
right
oh and that's all there is
good great
[Music]
okay once more oh chill out wait oh
i guess i wasn't gonna chill out
go upstairs and settle baby let me
actually see i didn't check if the
recordings had changed
no no no it's the same
hello baby
hello baby good night
kind of weird
perhaps a cheese toasty cheese toasty
all right we got
bread
cheese
bread make toasty
hell yeah
oh
my god feed them
[Laughter]
hey
okay
little rude little roo
okay
a little strange
look i just needed they say on airplanes
whenever the cabin pressure drops you
got to take care of yourself before you
take care of others that's just a fact
hi um
well baby you're just making it
infinitely harder for me to feed you
i was kind of a self-defeating thing
here
um
what oh i thought i threw it through
that door
can i get out of here okay hey baby hi
barbie
baby you you're so scary there you go
that's what you get all right i'm
changing you damn it
you better stay put no nappies better
come to life
i'm gonna be very okay hi baby did you
just t pose on me
did that baby just t pose on me
oh hi baby
listen baby you're being a little
extreme about all this
break the emergency glass ow
oh wow okay that's rude
whoa okay okay all right
cool
hey baby
maybe
get pacified
wow
[Music]
i don't remember that i think that's a
new feature
all right baby
no no no shush
hi baby you going to read me a story oh
you're big
oh you are gonna read me a story
hi
hi
baby why are you super weird why you so
weird it's not story time yet
settle baby baby can you settle
okay
could you settle
there you
go the correct plushie how about the
sheep
how about it
there you go
all right
it was cold throughout the palace
the moon shone bright outside
the wind it blew and blew oh no
the curtains flew open wide
the little prince was in his bed
and couldn't get to sleep
so he called out for his mother please
go and find my sheep
[Music]
i'm thirsty said the prince
so the sheep fetched a drink
i am dirty
said the prince
so the sheep changed his clothes
i'm tired
said the prince
let me count you
one
two
three
just one more thing
said the prince
before i drift to sleep
he opened up his big red eyes
and turned to face the sheep
come join me in my dreams
stay forever in my head
obediently the sheep stepped forth
its mind
consumed
by
what was that about a haster
pastr
he's too
hello hi baby
i remember this i think
wow
baby
just t-posts on me again
get a knife
good
night thank you thank you for that thank
you very much for that um so that that
basically is just a
re-polished version of what came before
that i played in
uh said three scary games but now
there's another feature escape unlocked
follow the white rabbit and escape from
the baby and i gotta imagine the other
six must be in the other
game
mode which is
you said that i unlocked it
you said that i unlocked it
you said you said i unlocked it so where
is it well i'll figure this out okay one
second
it's a new day
escape unlocked follow the way rabbit
didn't escape from the baby
[Music]
i literally couldn't figure it out
before and i came back another day and i
was like i'm gonna try it and
is that what i have to do
no
no
oh did i freak it up
oh i freaked it up didn't i no i didn't
freak it up
follow the white rabbit
oh
i just needed to play the damn game
ah
okay bye baby
bye baby
i got two in my own head about oh
oh
all right fine then
i'm not gonna complain about it i'm just
gonna play through them
what is that
hello
i guess i'm going down
really i needed to do oh
come on
all right then fine i guess i'll just um
find some cat's souls then
okay
hello
find another elevator why it seems to
have gone all the way down even if it
crashed
hmm
any cats
cat
i almost miss you
hey
horny
is that what you said
kitty
kitty kitty
a pikmin
a pikmin
okay why
hi hey baby
ah
oh baby you come back here you give me
that i gotta look for a cat
how to disappear
madness to music
um
one second baby gotta go bathroom
you find that funny huh
um
whoa
what
the award is hung upside down turning
your head you read nominated for best
use of color and music worst uh
best debut album best horror soundtrack
yellow song
hello
baby
hi baby
yeah okay
[Music]
little rude
piano music
okay
i'm guessing i need to do something with
this
youtube no
no
not piano music
all right you stop that now
piano music
award for best newcomer okay broken
guitar okay
espresso yourself through music
all right fine then
ah
hey what are you doing over there what
was that all about
[Music]
okay
[Music]
how about this one
god no
well this is lovely i'm just gonna go do
this and then play the music and
hopefully something cool happen
hi baby
[Music]
i don't think that's the music that's
written how okay
you okay baby okay
all right then secret switch sure that's
fine oh
maybe you're okay with this because i'm
gonna go in this hole all right bye
farewell
[Music]
don't mind me baby
i'm sure this won't be nightmarish
it's nightmarish oh goodness king's
lullaby
okay
listen to king's lullaby
oh
you steamy [ __ ]
good god
i'm a man i'm a man you think that you
can keep it for me i'm a man what's
nothing
suck it up grow up
you don't always get it your way
life's gonna come crashing down around
you and then you have to pay taxes then
you'll cry anyway you're pushing that uh
record through the thing there all right
goodbye
[Music]
yay
i did it
call elevator preferably one that works
[Laughter]
ah
you're funny you're funny
i imagine i'm gonna be going over there
oh damn the power's out
all right this way i suppose
okay
okay
the king arrives soon or soon the king
arrives
okay
ah that seems like power
oh
i don't feel
well that's a problem four three
[Music]
one please
hmm
okay
kitty kitty
kitty kitty
seventeen
four three one seven well that's easy
smith
ah
fuse i'm guessing four three one seven
well i guess right uh i don't think so
i don't cut
run
oh
wow
okay
that's uh
that's not normal i'm gonna go ahead and
think that's not normal all right no
power
wrong fuse of course it is wham oh yeah
oh
you stupid bad thank you
all right that was unnecessary
i'm gonna put you down you go down the
baby shoot goodbye
[Music]
whip let him close that up and uh
slap a fuse in this bad boy
done so
you put a baby down and shoot easy peasy
easy bees me
wow
are you upset
it seems like someone might be a little
bit upset
all right um well i don't know what to
do about that
all right let's have a talk baby okay
i'm gonna have a nice conversation about
how
you're
you're a baby and i'm an adult
i
i'm guessing that you're leaving me
leading
why is the floor all wibbly
that's probably fine
hmm
hi baby
[Music]
no that's not good
oh god uh what do i do do i go oh i i
don't do that
[Music]
no
please
please
oh god no
i do run i do run
running is what i do
good convenient uh resurrection
oh key wait wait wait wait key
haha easy easy i'm so good at games
god damn i'm good give me the
uh green moon
yellow triangle boom i'm oh god here we
go
idiot
that's stupid take one of those
oh my god
baby you can't beat an elevator door
stupid
that was fun actually that was a lot of
fun i like that a lot hmm
hi baby
[Music]
hi baby aren't you just the sweetest
thing well you come here with me oh you
come here with me we're gonna have a
good old time it's locked down here okay
well i'm a babysitter so i don't i don't
suppose i have any reason not to take
care of this baby
come here baby there you go what are you
doing looking like that oh come here
stinky
oh ain't too sweet
thank you sweet
no
you come back here now there you go
well ain't you just the sweetest baby
ain't you just so sweet ain't you just a
double
[Music]
oh you're stinky i think he
hm
i don't know where a new nappy would be
but i'm supposing that i'm supposed to
not be stupid about this and i'm
supposed to gather these up
and then uh yeah yeah i get it i get it
i get it
well that's not the right key
all right i got the key
and
wham
[Music]
that's pretty nice
hello
ah deja vu already seen already know
already lived
uh-huh
ah baby let's go to bed
you'll never you i didn't use this
weirdest thing i wasn't looking for cats
oh i totally forgot about the cats i
totally forgot about the cats baby can i
go back no it's too late i'll just go
back later
baby oh
this is a nice bedroom
they're real nice there you go cat
all right good night baby good night
good night good night
oh
i bet there were there were cats in that
other area so baby uh when do i get out
of here and when do i get paid because
the only reason that i would be doing
any sort of babysitting would be for
money
and i'm guessing that you as a baby
don't have a lot of money so who are
your parents and how are they going to
pay me
oh well bam goodnight baby
don't
oh
don't
hey it's a baby all right later baby
okay bye
wow that's a fantastic baby
that's a real good baby
wow
exploding baby
all right goodbye baby
later baby
you're feeling sleepy no i'm not oh god
oh ye gods nope you can't beat me oh not
today years of slender man have
programmed me to dodge you
you'll never get me i don't even know
who you are where you are
hey whoa i bet there was cats in there
i bet there were cats
maybe
whoa hi baby
nope not gonna trick me
not today
not today but no cat but not today
hi baby
well you grumpy oh who's being a grumpy
gus
who's being a grumpy baby boy
uh baby boy
grumpy
grumpy baby boy bedtime
grumpy baby boy
grumpy grumpy baby boy
the grumpiest of baby boys
fun
fun
nope
hi
hello
oh kitty
all right
uh
well you know uh
jerry you know why why wouldn't i put
this baby to bed why would i not put
this baby to bed why would i not do that
that seems like the exact look at this
baby this baby wants to go to bed
why wouldn't i do that there you go baby
oh
well that doesn't seem like you're boy
well i i don't think that was
the proper response small and harmless
if left unfed ears perked i sharp with
dread fleeing alone from dark carcosa
i don't know what dark carcosa is
all right you know baby i tried to be
nice but you're kind of a
mean
i don't like that
all right goodbye baby
i gotta go
i gotta go all right i gotta go see it
uh
i don't seem to be going
oh
do i need to throw the baby into the
abyss
i think i might need to do
you know what's coming oh you know big
baby boy it's it's so weird because i
know this is a big head mode but i can't
think of it any other way now we
hey
bye baby
oh
okay
freedom
freedom
alone afraid vulnerable
hi
hello
okay
little weird
okay who is the rabbit
and why is the rabbit helping me
i do not know
[Music]
oh my god i can't go backwards i'm dead
[Music]
usually my first instinct is to back up
but uh that did not go oh
okay i'm gonna get it this time
goodbye
oh god don't leave why
why wouldn't i cat i got all of them
[Music]
something unlocked in the lounge
oh [ __ ]
oh god dude
okay cowardice yes please
don't even think about it don't even
think about it
what am i doing what am i doing
okay i see a way through here
little baby boo don't look like that
i
am going to be just fine
well
then little rabbits you're not the only
one there will always be more we always
have fun
out in the sun
oh
oh my god
and that's it
the black cat approaches
coming soon in 2022
very fun
very fun but now i've got new stuff no
hat disguise let's see what the doctor's
gift is i'm very curious of what that's
about now i get to enjoy
[Laughter]
oh hello sir i thought i was babysitting
a baby ah you and the missus must not be
out yet
don't mind me just point me to where
that baby is and all
i'll fix him right up uh he's gonna be
just fine don't you worry about a thing
uh
uh let's see uh you look a little dirty
there we go
yeah enjoy that sir
all right good job well done
all right well you have a good night
what is this doctor's gift
doctor
oh right
oh i'm an idiot this was here the whole
time
okay
potion bottle
whoa oh
okay well that was one baby
you okay babe okay well that was one
option um
blue
ah
you're tiny
oh
red
holy crap
wow
that was awesome
all right baby
uh yellow
oh
that's good i think well that was baby
in yellow i wanted to go back to the
main menu but i guess i'm done thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed that that was very fun i did
enjoy that lot of polish on there and
apparently there have been 60 million
downloads of that game which by most
game metrics is uh
that's pretty damn impressive that's
pretty damn good so i gotta give it up
to them i like the style it's and come
it's a fun idea and it's pretty cool so
thank you everybody so much for watching
hey do you want to check out a cool
podcast called distractible why don't
you look in the description below for me
bob and wade talking about a bunch of
nonsense we've had some banger episodes
lately not gonna lie i think people can
attest if you've listened to
distractible and you've enjoyed the
episodes lately you can say in the
comments how much you've liked them and
that way other people can check it out
for themselves let us know what your
favorite is thank you and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you